does Hogwarts Legacy actually hate
Hogwarts this video right here is one
that popped up in my feed recently and
one that I had seen recommended a couple
times by a few different people so I
thought it would be fun to actually
watch this video with you guys and then
for me to react to it in real time and
see if some of these criticisms are
valid uh of course everyone is entitled
to their own opinion right but in the
aftermath of Hogwarts Legacy if you will
I have seen so many thoughts and
opinions flooding forward about this
game from fans from casual fans from
people who weren't really interested
great Title by the way I got to say it
definitely caught my eye definitely
intrigued me and I'm curious to hear
more which is you know what you want out
of any title over 340,000 views 14,000
likes as well so let's dive in and see
what he has to say here no matter where
you tried to run no matter where you
tried to hide for months on end you
could not escape the name Hogwarts
Legacy this game was absolutely
everywhere beating you into submission
whether you liked it or not at least
that is until it wasn't when Hogwarts
Legacy dropped off the face of the
planet about a week after release okay a
lot of people I've heard this one from a
lot of people that Hogwarts suaz dropped
off the planet a week after release so
this particular criticism is certainly
not original to this video I've heard
this in several places and I'm going to
push back a bit against that because a I
don't really know what people are
expecting out of a single player game I
mean sure you have games like the Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild where
there's so much to do and so many unique
things to figure out that people play it
for years on end I'm not that's what
people were expecting with Hogwarts
Legacy but I also don't think it's a
really fair expectation for the game or
even a fair way to judge a game by how
many people are still playing it or how
many people are still interested in it
that far after launch or however far
after launch that you want to determine
at the same time I would also push back
on that and say I still hear of plenty
of people who are playing and enjoying
the game I'm not personally I got the
platinum trophy in it and was done with
it from there I'm sure I'll go back and
revisit and play it again probably when
it comes out on the Nintendo switch then
we also have this recent video from Luke
Stevens and I think it's really
interesting to look at these videos in
contrast to one another because Luke
going into Hogwart pacy was very
skeptical he actually had me on one of
his videos where we talked it out and he
kind of let me share my thoughts on why
I was hyped for the game he shared his
thoughts on why he had a lot of
questions and was very skeptical of the
game that's kind of his thing going into
games being very skeptical asking
questions about them he posted a video
recently about how he went back to
Hogwarts Legacy and is pleasantly
surprised at how much it holds up and
how much he is still enjoying the game
he said no it's not going to win game of
the year it's not in that upper echelon
of video games but at the same time he
found himself really enjoying it and
then we have videos like this which you
know we're still watching it here but it
seems to be like this is going to be
coming in on the other side a little bit
and then lastly maybe it's because I've
been covering this game for so long I
know that there are still a ton of you
out there still playing Hogwart pyy I
hear from people all the time in Twitter
in the comments saying that yeah I'm
still playing some of you even saying
that you haven't beaten the game yet
because you're just having so much fun
exploring let's continue on here so much
excitement so much positivity and then
nothing nothing I repeat nothing what
was that right there people positivity
and then nothing most Hy players aren't
finishing the game hm I'm not familiar
with that article I would have to look
into that I think part of that could be
what I was just talking about is that so
many of you so many of the Diehard fans
are just enjoying being in that world I
mean one of the biggest fans that I know
James expect to go no knock on James
here he would happily tell you he took
weeks months Maybe even to actually beat
the game same thing for Benjamin snow
because they were just having such a
good time being immersed in that world
and they didn't want to be rushed
through it I also happened to know a lot
of people have the platinum trophy and
Hogwart sey so again I'd have to look
into this to see the data behind it but
players not finishing games I mean that
is true for the majority of games people
don't finish games all the way through
nothing I repeat nothing it turned out
the long-term staying power that so many
single player games have these days
games half a decade or more older well
that just wasn't there at all for
Hogwarts leg
okay so so now we're getting into a
little bit of his sort of expectations I
guess you know he shows The Witcher he
shows Red Dead of hoping that this would
be a game that we could put on that
level so I'm going to let it play a
little bit more here because I don't
want to assume a few things but I will
point out the two games that he just
reference CD project red and Rockstar so
keep that in mind but let's let's watch
a little bit more here f it following
the same exact formula why is that well
the answer I think all hinges on one
major mistake this first attempt at an
open world Hogwarts game made in my
opinion to be UPF front here this video
is something I've kneed off my chest for
quite a while but I've done my waiting 7
months of it so here we go so I think
that's an important point that he makes
there you know this is his opinion
totally and also it's something that
he's been thinking about for seven
months so this is not just him flying
off the cuff it's not just some random
video that came to his head something
that he's been planning for a while so
let's continue on Hogwarts Legacy is the
most frustrating Game of the Year not
because it's bad not at all but instead
because it absolutely Nails what it
needed to most most but then seems to
enter a race against itself to abandon
everything it does best let's start with
okay okay interesting I'm C I'm curious
to see where we go from here with the
obvious the castle itself it's beautiful
now I don't know how many of you
watching fall into the same boat as but
Hogwarts Legacy was my most anticipated
game ever those movie tie-ins were
amazing as a kid but they were thrown
together in months to meet a deadline
and while some of them hold up the
untapped potential was off the charts
for a fully realized Hogwarts I couldn't
wait for this game and by the way this
is coming from someone
who every single year except for one
when I went to Shrek which was a fuing
disaster but that's a story for another
time oh my goodness okay so whoa there's
a mod right there also very good context
right there so this is coming from
someone who is a very big Harry Potter
fan I believe he said it was his most
anticipated game of the year maybe even
said ever right there but Hogwarts
Legacy was my most anticipated game ever
those movie tie-ins were amazing yep
there it is most anticipated game ever I
love going back and talking about the
old games they had a certain charm to
them as he kind of alludes to here rough
around the edges and obviously they had
to be built in a very short amount of
time trying to hit those movie deadlines
but okay so this gives us a little bit
more context this is not just some hater
flying into hate on the game he actually
really cares about this world has been a
fan for a while and I now I'm starting
to I'm starting to kind of uh pieced
together where I think this could be
going because I've said this a few times
I feel like the most vehement criticisms
that I've seen well I don't know
vehement may be too strong of a word for
this video we'll see we haven't played
it all out yet but some of the most
vehement criticisms I have seen are from
people who are DieHard fans of the
series and trust me this was me whenever
the books released and then you had the
movies release I was the biggest critic
of the movies because I had such high
expectations there's that word
expectations remember that we're going
to keep coming back to that but I had
such high expectations for the movie and
then when they fell well short of the
books even though of course I'm able to
look back now and say yes they are very
well done movies but I still don't think
they come anywhere close to the books
point is if there's one thing this game
needed to get right it was the castle
100% agree I said this going well before
the game launched I said Hogwart pacy
especially when we started finding out
more about the open World stuff I said
the castle has to be number one you're
calling it Hogwarts Legacy we know we're
not going to have any of those
characters that we know from the main
series but you have to be able to nail
the castle because that's the one thing
that connects us to all these other
things those first 10 15 hours in
Hogwarts are where the game Peaks
there's not really anything to find in
terms of interesting Collectibles mostly
just a near infinite amount of clothing
items but what the castle does have are
quite a few little references and
details that zero attention is brought
to no attention is brought to um I would
say I mean you do have the field guide
pages so maybe he's going to talk about
those here in a bit as far as the loot
and the
Collectibles 99% agree there the
majority of the
Collectibles they they were a bit rough
that that needed to be completely
reworked I mean as you got later into
the game you get to a point where you're
just getting the same item or
unidentified item you go through a whole
cave and solve a puzzle and then it's
unidentified clothing item or it's
something that is actually less level
than what you already had so all that
stuff was definitely a bit rough I
assume we're going to hear more about
that as we proceed but as far as the
castle goes we'll see if he expands on
this a bit but you know I mean there
were the field guide pages and there's
also the actual guide book where you can
go through the collectibles in there
let's keep going the game doesn't throw
them in your face because they exist for
you to seek out you being the book fan
or the movie fan and I love the game
most things Y what I don't love is that
Hogwarts Legacy puts this amazing Castle
in front of your face and then kicks you
out of it into way less interesting
areas for most of the game I'm afraid
this is the end of Hogwarts one of the
biggest M I got to say great edits by
the way too I love these movie clips
that he's pulling in now this was a big
concern for a lot of people going into
the game is that I don't really want to
be pulled out of Hogwarts you know this
is a a school that we have wanted to
explore for years and as he pointed out
back in those old games you couldn't
really do it they tried a little bit but
to have a fully realized Hogwarts would
you would be able to go room to room I
mean that was the dream and for the most
part for me personally I feel like for
the most part they nailed it I do have
my own criticisms as well but then you
also have the open world aspect I mean
for a while we didn't even know that
there was going to be all this area
surrounding Hogwarts and I can
definitely see how this was a big point
of debate and a big point of
disagreement among fans I personally
enjoyed most of the open World stuff I
do still feel like there are flaws in
the open world I wish it would have tied
back more into the overall lore of The
Wizarding World and I I feel like I
would have rather them cut certain
sections of these and give us things
like the ministry of magic give us
godric's Hollow I mean it's in the
Wizarding World you can literally
apparate you have that feature right
there that is perfect for being able to
to quickly hop between different parts
of the world and they didn't really do
that I mean for the longest time leading
into the game I thought this whole idea
of this ancient magic was going to be us
going to these different iconic
Wizarding World locations I mean I
mentioned a couple already as caban as
well is another one which you get to see
a little bit if you play as a Hufflepuff
but as far as the open world I mean I
enjoyed parts of the open world but I
would say it's definitely not the
strongest part of the game however I
don't think I would want the game not to
have it Stakes Hogwarts Legacy makes is
having this huge sprawling map South of
the castle that offers almost nothing
and I find it to be such a misfire
because whether it was realized or not
that sprawling map came at a major cost
one that slowly but surely infects
degrades and cheapens nearly every last
corner of this game by the end and well
let me explain before saying anything
else I want to be clear that as an idea
there's no problem with massive open
worlds or even certain types of filler
content in fact I think there can be a
place for filler in games as long as it
isn't taking away from things that that
are far more important Hogwarts Legacy
though
well this game has about 40 hours worth
of content that just should not exist
not when there are 40 hours worth of
content that should not exist wow I
don't even know if I
played 40 hours on my initial
playthrough okay yeah I had to look this
up here main story takes about 26 and
1/2 hours on average to get through main
story plus the side quest about 43 and2
hours and if you are a completionist
you're looking at around 672 hours to
complete everything so I mean if you do
the math there basically everything
outside of the main story he feels like
was a waste of time now the thing I
don't know is does that include like the
Sebastian quest line the poppy quest
line the natsai quest line when they're
not part of the main story they're not
required to do any of those because if
that's the case obviously I would
definitely push back against that and
say no especially in the case of
Sebastian that is uh arguably even more
important than the main story and has
more repercussions than the main story
now I want to point out it's not that
spending time south of the castle is an
awful experience I mean at least it's an
excuse to listen to this game's amazing
soundtrack Hogwarts Legacy really
desperately needed was Focus this isn't
a game that you can accuse of not having
a ton of resources put towards it I mean
it was in development for six entire
years and for whatever reason so much of
that time and effort was spent on a
Barren open world and tons of areas that
bizarrely make almost no use of The
Wizarding World
license okay that's that's kind of what
I was alluding to there earlier when I
was saying I do wish more of the open
World stuff would have somehow
Incorporated more Wizarding World
elements make it somehow tie back into
the lore I mean even if you have to get
a little bit creative I mean they can
certainly use their creative license
this is all under WB and portkey games
it doesn't have to fit with exactly
everything we know and of course as book
nerds we want it to fit as much as
possible but they definitely had some
room here where they could have expanded
things in that open world plus they
could have even tied it back to those
specific locations that we already
talked about like asab ban we do see
gring gots in the game Ministry of magic
all those other opportunities as well
some way that turn your brain off with a
podcast on content the kind that you
could also get from any other open world
game well that stuff somehow took
priority over much of what was really
needed inside and around Hogwarts the
unfortunate on the pitch in last Springs
final this year's qu season has been
cancelled that's
rubb I still say quidditch did not need
to be in this game and does not need to
be in this game I know I'm in the
minority and it seems like that Minority
is shrinking of more and more people
saying that quid should have definitely
been in I personally don't have a
problem with it but I at least get where
people are coming
from maybe some of you will disagree
with what I'm about to say I don't know
but I would trade every single Merlin
trial every last cave with nothing but a
meaningless piece of clothing in it
every nonsensical alohamora miname and
all right hold on let's keep track of
this he would trade all the Merlin
trials all the alohomora mini games all
of the caves demig statue south of
Hogwarts I trade all of that in a
heartbeat for even half of what's
missing or barely there inside and
around the castle I don't need to
explore an empty cave for the 687 time
the first two were more than enough in
the most brutal way they're almost C
honestly I don't know if I would trade
all of it I would definitely trade a
significant portion of it though I am
with him there to keep things feeling
fresh I do feel like you need to change
up the setting a little bit I don't
think you need to be at Hogwarts the
entire time and we even see this
throughout the books we see this
throughout the movies they don't just
stay at Hogwarts for the entire time and
then you look at book Seven I mean it
takes place almost entirely outside of
Hogwarts until the end so I think you do
need that to kind of keep things fresh
however I do agree that it may have been
a little bit too much and if some of
those resources had been put more into
the castle then we might have gotten
more fun things to do in there where we
don't even want to leave the castle one
of the most memorable moments I got out
of this entire game not in a good way in
this was when I solved a little puzzle
on the outside Bridge of Hogwarts the
puzzle itself was great but after
solving it I took a look at the game's
Field Guide how you track your progress
and I saw that what I just solved was
one out of three Hogwart Secrets yes
three for the entire Castle that's a
good 95 Merlin trials in the countryside
that that that's a good point no we do
have the field guy pages so I'll push
back a bit on that but man I haven't
looked through that guide book in a
while to see if there is anything else
tying to Hogwarts but that is pretty
funny that there 95 not an exaggeration
by the way and also they're really the
same five repeated about 20 times each
the Merlin trials man everybody hates on
the Merlin trials 95 I agree probably a
little bit too much but again it's
optional you know they weren't they
weren't required you didn't have to do
all 95 unless you're Trophy Hunter like
me yet there's three Hogwart secrets in
total or maybe you didn't notice they're
three now in case you haven't played the
game I don't want to misrepresent things
there are the little visual details in
the castle I already mentioned as well
as Collectibles that the game doesn't
count as being secrets and right so
because they're all the very
straightforward kind that are times over
you know see a certain type of door with
a mini game on it solve that mini game
for the nth time and you're in I'll be
waiting to open the door don't give me
they are straightforward and that's also
something that when they make a Hogwarts
like a sequel which I'm fairly certain
they will I don't know the best way to
handle that because of course you want
to have Hogwarts as a central location
one of the main locations that you keep
going back to However the fact that
we've already discovered a lot of these
secrets you can't just do Field Guide
Pages again so they would have to up
their game they would have to figure out
some other way to keep things
interesting inside the castle wrong
that's stuff is not awful in fact I was
constantly reminiscing back to those
Collectibles when the game forced me
outside of the castle for the other 85%
of them inside Hogwarts and by extension
immediate surroundings including
hogsmead well the Collectibles didn't
even really register as a grind because
I was entertained enough running around
the castle very true time flies when
one's having fun however when I was
grinding out the points of disinterest
in the 14th identical wizard Hamlet
south of Hogwarts that had zero
distinguishing features from the last 13
well I couldn't help but to think of how
much better of a time I'd be having in
the castle or in hogsmeade and how much
better spent development time would have
been in those areas what that's what you
think that's what I think let's quickly
talk about the Hogwarts professors
because they're may be the single best
example I can come up with of this game
just sprinting away from what it does
best wait what so the devs of Hogwarts
Legacy Avalanche did an absolutely
incredible job of coming up with a new
roster of professors okay let's go I was
about to say don't you can't hate on
these professors they they nailed the
professors now where I'm guessing he's
going to go with this is that they
weren't in there enough which if that's
where he goes I completely agree the
professors were incredible and we did
not get enough of them for sure I'm a
dork so at launch I bought the concept
art book for Hogwarts Legacy and looking
through it I mean it's beyond obvious
that everyone responsible for bringing
these new professors to life realized
the expectations fans were going to have
I mean how exactly do you follow up the
professors of the books and the movies
who were all so memorable go on well the
the answer is that you do it like
Avalanche did because they knocked it
out of the park Professor sharp Weasley
Ron and garlic I remember them and I
still say they mirror very very closely
a lot of the Hogwarts professors that
that we already know I mean you can see
clearly a lot of the similarities in the
professors that we get from the main
Harry Potter books and I think that was
100% intentional in fact a lot of people
said that they were too close going in I
think they had enough here to
distinguish it but you really only got
to see some of those true true
distinguishing factors when you like
went into their private areas of the
castle and you would read notes and
certain things you didn't get enough of
that in the actual main plot of the game
all especially garlic for some reason
but unfortunately Hogwarts like yo
that's my thumbnail right there that's
my thumbnail from uh the video I made on
the Hogwarts professors Legacy presents
you with this really great lineup and
then just completely forgets about them
so you can go commit mass murder and pop
balloons in some generic Countryside you
know it would be
really entertaining to see what the
reaction would have been before launch
if it had slipped out that in this 70ish
hour game you only go to most of your
classes a single time for about five
minutes and okay all right so here we're
starting to
see what his expectations were for the
game now I had a hunch going in that the
classes were not going to be this
multiple Persona like Bully like thing
where you really feel like you're a
student and I think there were a lot of
people who wanted that how many wanted
that that's what I'm not really clear on
I I don't know I mean clearly the game
sold very well the game reviewed very
well among both critics and fans alike
and at the same time this is something
that I keep hearing is that people
wanted more of that student likee
experience rather than us being the
chosen one and you know being this all
powerful wizard that we can run around
the countryside and basically dominate
any Wizard and you know criticism he
hasn't mentioned yet that I assume has
to be coming is the lack of consequences
and the fact that you can just run
around using AK and no one even really
cares but uh I I definitely feel where
he's coming from on this one a th% we
needed more of the professors and I
don't know that I'm in the camp of I
wanted it to be a
full Persona like student simulator but
we absolutely needed more of it than
what we got I I I will agree with that
professor gets one or maybe two cut
scenes almost all of which are in the
first 10 to 15 hours now make sure you
also go back if you guys haven't seen
this or if you're going to play the game
for the first time I assume most people
watching this have already played the
game but if you didn't know you can
return back to the professors and have
these additional conversations where you
learn a bit more in fact that's how you
actually learn about professor heket and
that she's actually a lot younger uh
than she appears after that the game
just kind of gives up on any feeling of
you being a student because you're too
busy slaughtering every human and Goblin
who ever lived with zero repercussions
there it is there it is I knew I was
like he's going to mention the lack of
of repercussions has to on ran Rock's
hands spoken like a true politician on
the topic of goblin Slaughter something
that hey shout out again to these edits
I love I can't imagine how long it took
him to actually go and find all those
movie clips and time that up perfectly
that's a good stuff of course comes up
frequently here on this channel how
about that main story which again almost
entirely falls into the Trap of Hogwarts
not
recognizing strengths now I won't spoil
it because there's really no reason to
but the main quest line is the type that
could be summed up in about 2 seconds
because the premise basically is the
entire story you're the chosen one more
or less and there also happens to be a
goblin Rebellion going on so go kill
thousands of them and figure out why
you're the chosen one which will
definitely play out exactly how you
think it will because this is the safest
main quest of all time now I'll say this
safest that's that's exactly what I've
called it too now I say the setup I felt
like the beginning man I I it was set up
incredibly well that first mission just
felt so cinematic I felt like I was
stepping right back into the movies and
again you you start at grot so I had
this idea in my head of you're going to
be going to all these different
Wizarding World locations and that's how
this is going to to play out we're going
to be discovering all this stuff about
ancient magic but yeah this this is a
valid criticism here uh the story I
think safe is the best way to describe
it it was okay I don't think it was bad
but it was it was definitely safe the
story doesn't really take a single twist
turn or chance and while it is fine it's
pass what gives me a headache is that
the main absolutely embarrassed by one
of the side story lines you probably
already about it's of course the quest
line with Sebastian and ominus I think
that the there's a debate among fans
like was this originally intended to be
the main quest you know there was that
rumor about it used to be called Dark
Legacy or Hogwarts Dark Legacy something
like that and clearly this story line
the Sebastian story line is far more
significance than the natai story line
the poppy story line and that is the
only one where you make meaningful
choices that have big time impact
especially the last one not going to
spoil it if you haven't seen it yet but
the last one in particular has I mean
that that will determine a major part of
the next game if they keep these same
characters so I don't know how they
would work that out because the decision
you make on Sebastian is a pretty big
one these two characters carried
Hogwarts Legacy They carried it hard
especially towards the end when their
story is one of the only reasons left to
ever be in Hogwarts I don't know how
many of you had the same experience but
it reached the point for me while
playing where my primary motivation for
continuing the main quest line was just
to unlock more of the Sebastian and
ominous and and what's interesting about
that quest line too is that part of it
kind of weaves in to the main story line
like Sebastian appears in some of the
main story missions so there were times
when I was playing I was kind of unclear
like wait is this a main story Mission
or is this a Sebastian Mission because
all the Sebastian missions to get the
unforgivable curses that's all entirely
optional and yet Sebastian also plays a
role in the main story as well he kind
of pops in and out of that one story
along the way whenever I'd get a new
objective related to them I'd Sprint
towards it immediately and have a good
time but when it was over I'd already
know exactly what was about to come next
I'd hang my head low and get ready for
yet another main quest where I
immediately leave Hogwarts to go kill a
bunch of goblins in the
countryside now I'm really depressed the
Sebastian story line well it really
should have been the main quest or at
least I think so drop the chosen one
thing that doesn't go anywhere
interesting and has done to death anyway
drop the goblin Rebellion that keeps us
out of Hogwarts and instead what could
have been so much more is a fleshed out
version of Sebastian and ominus is
storyline one that actually fits in with
the rest of the game as it is the
ominous Sebastian quest line is really
good but it's also pretty short a fair
amount of it happens without your
involvement and more importantly it
needed a lot of work to not be in
constant disagreement with everything
else that happens in this game it's the
Sebastian storyline that put some of the
most important choices this game has to
offer in front of you the ones related
to involved with some of the darkest
magic in this world those decisions
without exception are presented as being
super consequential points of no return
as they really needed to be if they were
going to make any sense but then shocker
they aren't consequential at all the
second you step out of Sebastian
storyline with only one exception
nothing you did within it matters even a
little bit I confess myself oh that's
perfect disappointed it's honestly
perfect use of that yeah yeah this this
is probably my biggest critique of the
game and anytime I've had a chance to
talk about it that is one that I bring
up is the lack of con quence and we
learned gosh I can't remember how close
it was to launch that we learned they
changed up the wording and they said
there was not going to be a morality
system you know leading up to the game
they talked a lot about choices and your
choices you know determining the fate of
The Wizarding World and the legacy of
Hogwarts all these things and I'm pretty
sure it was close to the game when they
updated the FAQ and it said there is no
morality system which there were a lot
of different interpretations of that but
what it essentially means is that your
choices don't really matter except for
some clearcut story decisions where it's
it's it's a it's a black and white you
choose this or you choose this there's
not a lot of room for nuance it's not
that Mass Effect style it's not even
like that Witcher style but I loved how
like Mass Effect and Infamous Star Wars
kns of the Old Republic where you can
see your charact when you if you want to
go down this dark path then you
physically see the character getting
darker your your powers actually change
up based on you making this decision now
of course there are some things they had
to do to keep it fit within the
Wizarding World and the rules that we
already have but that is a criticism I
think is is totally valid and one that I
would hope would be rectified in any
follow-up to the game kind of
embarrassing looking back now because
when Hogwarts Legacy came out this
channel had about a quarter of the
subscribers it does now and as a very
small Channel I was so excited at the
time to make some Hogwarts Legacy
content focused on the little things you
know choices consequences and all the
ways the Game responds to hey me too me
too didn't have a lot of that actions as
we all know now despite that being a
pretty huge part of the marketing well
there really isn't any of that I mean
you're free to become death destroyer of
the Scottish Countryside all you want
but the actual choices you make in
dialogue the ones that should be
gamechanging well they mean absolutely
nothing nothing of course as turns out I
can't get over these edits Dude Perfect
use of the movies man I love it and this
was news to me after having read the
books 40,000 times well the unforgivable
curses are actually extremely forgivable
your teachers don't care your other
friends don't care de doesn't give a
[__] about anything other than the
potions you brw so at least that's
consistent
but oh yes I bleeped that out we're
familyfriendly channel here but uh yeah
I mean my man Dee he's got one thing on
his mind and it's all about you Brewing
those potions point is no one cares what
unspeakable acts you've committed or
what dark magic you've decided to tamper
with and let's be honest it doesn't make
any sense Avalanche please if anyone
from the studio is watching I beg you to
consider my offer I would like to refund
50 Merlin trials and 27 Bandit camps in
exchange for even half of my choices
having consequences you can 100% agree
with that I would I would absolutely
agree with that for sure also have 250
square of the southern part of the map
back I'll throw that in for free I'd
also like to return the other 45 Merlin
trials plus I'll even include two dozen
empty caves in the pointless lockpicking
miname to sweeten the deal oh you know
what I forgot about one thing he didn't
touch on in Hogwarts I just remember
this now is the uh the puzzles herodian
I think it was all those puzzles those
were pretty difficult I would have liked
to have seen a lot more of those sorry
I'm laughing because I know some people
absolutely hated those puzzles but that
is one more thing inside Hogwarts uh
that he didn't touch on yet in exchange
for this game having a house point
system or more students to talk to
Companions that could join you on
adventures or a dueling club that lasts
more than 10 minutes I mean oh my gosh
duel yes and and this was such a strange
one because it was in the game I mean
they had a dueling Club in the game and
then it just ended I I can't imagine
that that was originally the intent
behind that for that to just go away and
not be a thing that persisted throughout
the entire school year and could
increase in ulty then you also had the
Summoner Court mini game with Professor
Ronan which also just kind of went away
that one persisted a little bit more
than the dueling Club but both of those
I feel like should have been things that
you could just walk up and challenge
other students anytime to do throughout
the rest of the year seriously what was
that about how do you introduce a
dueling Club the perfect setup for fun
combat within Hogwarts just get rid of
it after a few minutes it's an outrage
it's a scand you know one not very
convincing argument I've heard as to why
why in open world twice the size of
Pango was necessary is that without it
it wouldn't be possible to fit much
combat in to that I say well what as it
is hogwart's Legacy doesn't even come
close to making the most of the combat
opportunities that are already there in
the iconic parts of the map let alone
Wizarding Hamlet number 27 or plot of
land
713 like the Forbidden Forest entire
thing is that it's filled with dangers
of every sort and you never know what's
around the next Corner in Hogwarts
legacy's Forbidden Forest well that
couldn't be further from the truth
there's like five creature types to
fight in total and those same five are
just repeated endlessly across the
entire map there's more than werewolves
in and I will say the combat sure of
that now despite is is topn and that
seems to be pretty much something
Universal that most people agree the
combat is very well done my biggest
critique of the combat ties directly to
the items and the upgrades and also what
he's getting at here the enemies because
you have have all these upgrades all of
these boosts and abilities that you
never even actually need there's never
any situation where you can see like oh
when I go into this area I want to make
sure that I'm you know really protected
against spiders or I'm really protected
against goblins or I have you know my
Spell equipped that does more damage
against this there's a little bit of it
in terms of the puzzles and you have to
kind of change up which spells you use
for those but in terms of the different
enemies that you run into and even the
boss like enemies there just wasn't
enough of that variety and that
creativity there of using different
spells and using different abilities to
interact with those we we see him touch
on it a little bit there was the the
giant Knight where he had to use the
different spells and then the the final
boss where he had to use the different
spells I would like to see those be like
kind of the the first stage of that and
then by the end of the game we get
levels two three and four of them just
keep building on that to where we I mean
Zelda games have been doing this for
years right where you have all these
different sty of bosses and you need to
use different strategies to beat each
one and there's going to be certain
things that excel at different types of
bosses the lack of enemy variety I do
like the combat in this game a lot it's
honestly pretty impressive how solid it
ended up being one of the best that said
the one complaint thrown out most often
against it is that there just isn't
enough there to keep it interesting for
60 70 80 hours it was built for the more
Casual Gamer which in my opinion is
totally fine and appropriate for a game
like this this isn't Dudley Souls but
like so many other areas of Hogwarts
like true legy its combat would have
benefited greatly from less of a focus
on quantity you know the same encounter
spammed 50 times each which is what you
get and instead a focus on a little more
depth in some variety different enemy
types can do a lot to keep Simple combat
feeling fresh and this game just doesn't
have the excuse of there being limited
options I mean there's an entire
spin-off Potter book just filled with
dangerous
creatures and while I'm definitely not
saying we needed all of them in this
first game it does feel like a major
misfire to be spending most of your time
fighting skeletons wolves and spiders in
this world one that off very we know the
inury I don't think it was ever clear
who brought those INF Fury I mean maybe
it was Rookwood and we know toward the
end we see Sebastian with some of those
INF Fury but yeah that's an awful lot of
INF Fury just uh showing up randomly now
one thing he touched on there and
something that I think we need to expand
upon a bit is how this game really had
to appeal to a mass audience in his
words I think more casual fans and that
is certainly true I mean I know of fans
who literally bought a PlayStation 5
just to play this game they're not
experienced with games and they just
wanted to be in that world of Hogwarts
so I've always said that Avalanche
should be really commended for making a
thing making a product that is so
appealing to all these different types
of Gamers because that is an incredibly
difficult thing to do to make it
approachable for everyone and so what
you're seeing here is some of the hard
fans clearly a fan who's been a fan of
Harry Potter for a long time clearly a
gamer who knows games this is the same
boat I fall into you the type of game
that I would have made and the type of
combat scenarios that I would have set
up is not necessarily what we got in the
final game however it's possible that it
could be the most broad appeal now all
that being said I think he's making some
good points here about how you can still
do that and make it sort of easy to
understand and get into but there's got
to be more there there's got to be more
meat on the bone so to speak so that as
you keep playing through the game things
remain fresh and fun and interesting and
it all feels like it's moving at a good
Pace one that offers dozens of very
unique enemies the kind that you
couldn't get in a non- Wizarding World
game that's the part to really Hammer
home there are so many bits and pieces
of Hogwarts Legacy that don't take
advantage of what this franchise already
offers up on a silver platter as to that
most unfortunate no one regrets more
than I part of the re now I think one of
the reasons for that I do wonder if part
of it is
because they have this huge range of
Hogwarts fans that they want to appeal
to right of Harry Potter fans but then I
also think they wanted to pull in other
people as well maybe people who are only
casually interested in the series now I
think this is certainly a much smaller
number but I have heard from plenty of
people and I've gotten comments and
questions about people who say hey I'm
actually not that into Harry Potter but
I'm kind of into fantasy and this whole
uh you know action RPG style of game
would I be able to hop in and enjoy
Hogwarts Legacy so that's another
audience that Avalanche had to appeal to
as well so I just think that's another
thing to know another thing to consider
reason you haven't seen much Hogwarts
Legacy content since launch I think has
to do with this being a game that's
really difficult to break down in a way
that's fair even when you're Focus
solely on judging the game by its own
Merit on one hand I I'm sure many of you
are rooting for Avalanche software
famously not the type of Studio you
would have expected to be assigned a
huge project like this I mean their
crowning achievement pre Hogwarts Legacy
was Chicken Little Ace in action the
spin-off yo The Cars 3 slander come on
dude Chicken Little game and with that
in mind incredible work here it's a
wonder we didn't end up with Gollum
before Gollum existed on the other hand
I don't think that's a shield from all
of the very avoidable flaws baked into
the core of this game especially the
ones that feel really self-inflicted I
mean if you look into this game's files
you'll see tons of evidence of core
features that were in the works but
ultimately scrapped I'm talking house
points a reputation that that's going to
happen with any game and it's something
that I've said multiple times every game
is going to have things that they
originally wanted to include and ended
up not being able to it had to scale
back and cut we don't know the reasons
behind that knowing and talking with
some of the people at Avalanche I can
certainly say that they probably had
very good reasons for doing that we may
as fans not necessarily love those
particular reasons but I could rest
assured they they certainly had their
reasons for doing it well that brings us
full circle as to why Hogwarts Legacy is
one of the most frustrating games of the
year for me a pretty good game sure and
one I think of positively in a lot of
ways but okay and I think that's
important to say you know he made it
clear right there he does enjoy the game
thinks it's pretty good and he even
enjoyed it in a lot of ways so I think a
lot of times through these videos which
of course the main point is the critique
so that's what people are going to talk
about but I also think it's very
important which you know we touched on
earlier this is not somebody just hating
to hate on the game but once some time
passes after Avalanche you put out a
sequel or two and other Wizarding World
Games have come and gone because we know
they're coming after how this one sold
oh yeah well I think Hogwarts Legacy
will be looked back upon as more of a
good start than anything else it's a
flaw beginning saddled with the huge
mistake of biting off way more than it
could chew and as a result it left a ton
of room for improvement the positive
though is that Hogwarts Legacy is set
Avalanche up I was going to say that's I
think he's about to get to it that's not
necessarily I mean going forward that's
a good thing obviously you want it to
just release as the perfect game to
begin with but I've said this before I
think this is a a great beginning for
future Wizarding Ro games and that's why
I I hope so much that WB is going to
give Avalanche the freedom to take this
and run with it obviously we know the
game made a ton of money so they have
the resources there if they if they so
choose they have the resources to be
able to put into this and hopefully
deliver that game that it seems like
most fans really want to see uh I will
say
just for my own personal take I still
love Hogwarts Legacy uh I think I
probably liked it a little bit more than
neon here at the same time I agree with
the vast majority of these criticisms
and think he's making some really good
points here we've got just a couple more
seconds left here the video with an
incredible Foundation to build upon
coming next I'm looking forward to it
and there better be qu well that's all
for today if you enjoyed this there
better be quidditch oh my gosh I I won't
be mad but there are a lot of people who
will be mad now if you enjoy this type
of video where we really get into the
nitty-gritty and critique things then
you might want to check out this 4our
live stream right here I kid you not 4
hours of me fully breaking down Hogwarts
py and you know what I still think I
left a lot of things on the table I
still think there's even more to talk
about who knows maybe in a future video
let me know in the comments below what
do you agree with what do you disagree
with as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon